ben fogel ben relentlessly pursues
adventure
risk and challenge but this doesn't come
from a place of strength and courage
it comes from the opposite this if you
think you're gonna fail
you're gonna fail you just have to have
this positive attitude and it was only
actually working with
olympians that i've done now when i
climbed everest i realized you need this
confidence verging on arrogance that i
will
get to the top of this mountain three
weeks before he was due to be born
naturally and we lost our third child
and it was
an awful awful experience that
affected us profoundly i became really
introverted
i'd go to events and i'd find myself
going to the loo and just sitting
sitting in the little cubicle for the
duration of the whole
event big mistake we got death threats
and worse
i i shouldn't have shared this idea
in a social um media platform
but i was amazed at the vile vitriolic
abuse
[Music]
ben fogel he's a tv presenter
broadcaster and author
he's climbed mount everest he's trekked
across antarctica
and he's rode across the atlantic ocean
ben relentlessly pursues adventure risk
and challenge
but this doesn't come from a place of
strength and courage it comes from the
opposite
from a place that you would probably
never expect this was such a diverse
conversation we covered
so much and so many things ben has been
on the most incredible
journey tearing up the script and
ignoring the standard society
sets for all of us on this never-ending
continuous journey of rebuilding himself
as he says in his own words
and that journey has been inspired by
one simple idea
his desire to take back control of his
own
personal narrative something he believes
we've all lost control of
and this podcast is going to take you on
a journey from the need to a positive
attitude to resisting your labels to
taking leaps to rediscovering the
importance of simplicity
in your life that ben has learned from
living in the wilderness and
to answering the question that we all
seek to answer pretty much every day of
our lives which is how to be happier
and how to be more fulfilled so without
further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
diary of a ceo i hope nobody's listening
but if you are then please keep this to
yourself
[Music]
ben uh as i read through your
story your books your interviews and i i
remember remember watching
uh a youtube documentary of you sailing
across the atlantic many years ago
um obviously the most sort of striking
distinctive
standout thing about the way that you've
chosen to live your life over the last
couple of decades is your seemingly
insatiable appetite for adventure
risk challenge uh extreme adventure
as it relates to everest and things like
that where did that come from
i think it's do you know it's not
necessarily
an absolute thirst for adventure i think
it's about kind of
finding the real me see if i go if i go
right back as a child i was
so shy i had no confidence i failed all
my exams i was
hopeless at sport and actually i think
it i think all of the things that i've
done
since have been about like rebuilding
and it sounds it sounds a weird way to
describe it but it's not
just i'm not an adrenaline junkie
there's there's this assumption that
maybe
you know that that would be how to
describe
myself but it's not that at all actually
those are the things i do are really
really slow
you know like rowing across the atlantic
took best part of two months
walking across antarctica took many many
months climbing everest took
many months so actually if if it was
jumping off a mountain base jumping or
going uh
on a motorbike or even a mountain bike
down a steep slope
i hate all that it's too fast i quite
like
this slow movement but i'm quite good at
long endurance events and all of those
have been about
rebuilding my confidence and what took
your confidence or why didn't you have
confidence i think i think it's the fact
that i was
i was hopeless academically for many
different reasons undiagnosed
dyslexia um a kind of
a slight mistake maybe not on my parents
part but they
my father's canadian he wanted me to be
bilingual so i was sent to a french
school
and i just i just i just didn't
i couldn't do the french school the
french system and with all apologies to
any french
watching or listening to this it's just
quite a hard system
the french one and and and it was quite
it was quite um strict
and i'm just i as a child i just i was
surrounded by dogs dad was a vet
mum was an actress it was all quite a
liberal my actual childhood at home was
quite liberal
full of actors um lots of drink
lots of animals around it was i suppose
crazy but normal for me
but then in this french system it was
very rigid and
and it meant that i didn't learn any
french and my english went backwards
so when i went back into the system i
was way behind and it
and the result was the combination of
that and dyslexia
just meant i was hopeless i could barely
write and i
and i failed all my exams and i was
surrounded by people who were better
than me at everything everyone everyone
seemed to be more handsome when it c
if it was the boys they had more luck
with the girls they were better at
playing
um sports because they could actually
kick football unlike me that have i have
two left legs
and and they were good at um academics
and when it came to the exams they just
they didn't even you know they could be
up all night watching stuff and then the
next day turn up for the exam whereas i
was just
i was almost making myself vomit i was
so nervous about the exams because i
knew i was gonna fail
and this is this is the first thing i
convinced myself i'd fail
and of course i ended up failing because
what i've discovered
since is that so much of what we do and
what we endure and how we intest
ourselves
is here in the mind and if you go in
with a negative attitude which
i had then it's self-fulfilling
and and the result was hopeless is
everything and it just stripped me of my
confidence
i i had you know i just i didn't
believe in myself and that that went
right through
you know probably into my 30s if i'm to
be really honest i think that was always
lingering over me this little voice just
telling me
that i was uh that i wasn't good enough
at what i did and did that voice come
from
your own assessment of yourself or was
was there external forces bullying or
your parents or no my parents were
amazing you know
my parents have i don't think they could
have done more
for me than they did i think it was
no i think it was all internal if i'm to
be honest
i think there's a pres i think there was
an external pressure
to conform because if you think about
how
if you take the schooling model in the
education model it is
kind of about conforming because exams
are all about
getting the the correct grades we're
we're learning to
a specific model that has been um set
by the government and and it's it's sort
of painting by numbers when it when you
think about education and if you don't
hit those targets then then you've
effectively failed the
system and for me you can hear from my
accent you know i'm i'm posh i went to a
private school mum and dad worked really
hard
to send me to a private school and
actually there was a great guilt
that the fact that they had worked so
hard
to be able to afford to send me there
and yet i still failed
so i think actually a lot of that voice
was internal
and actually i wish if i could go back
in time i wish i could kind of shake my
shoulder
shake a young me on the shoulders and go
just
don't don't overthink things just chill
out a little bit
and we were you a chronic overthinker i
was and i still am absolutely i still
overthink things if i'm to be honest i
i i to work in the medium that i work in
is a little bit strange because i don't
really belong in this medium when i say
this medium you know
front of house as a presenter because
i've got a really thin skin and i
overthink everything so when i read
something negative whether that's on
social media whether that's a newspaper
review whether that's a journalist that
has
written something um which i don't like
um or which doesn't seem true
i take it really personally which is
kind of really strange because i should
have
i should have been able to overcome that
after 20 years and i'm almost there
stephen i'm almost there but one of the
reasons i'm happy to talk about it is
because i know so i'm i know i'm not
alone i know there are many many people
out there
who are high achievers who've done
brilliant things in life
but are still burdened with their own
voice of doubt
and through all of these challenges i've
done
i've been able to really build that
confidence and i'm i'd say
i'm a few hundred meters from the summit
now of
peak confidence and i can't wait until
i'm there
i hope i do i i hope i reach that point
what is it about those challenges
and this sort of slow monotonous nature
of those challenges or just the
challenges themselves or challenge
as a you know as a as a construct itself
that helped you to build confidence
because i'm
one of the most frequent questions i'm
asked in the comments section of this
podcast or on instagram or anywhere else
is
um how do i build my confidence and i
think we live in a
culture especially on instagram where it
seems like everyone else
is super confident and chasing their
dreams
and we we never get to hear the whispers
of their self-doubt so it
might feel like we're the only ones so i
guess my question is
how how did those challenges build your
confidence
it happened by accident so that's the
first thing to say i didn't chase it
thinking this is going to help
it was like a slow series of blocks that
were built so
it started when i failed my a-levels and
i went off traveling i went to
costa rica a place that i know you love
and i went to university out there
and i think it was spending time in a
different culture
in a different culture country with a
different culture different
language different religion away from
home away from mum and dad
and and first of all i had to kind of
think on my own i couldn't defer to
other people
up until that point i'd always kind of
dad what do you what do you think mum
what do you
should i do you know i i i didn't trust
my own judgment so first of all that was
gone so i had to
stand or fall on my own decisions and
then
secondly just the immersion in this
exciting new
place was just i mean it just
it it was the most exciting year i've
ever had if i'm to be really honest
and i decided then that that that's what
i wanted from life i didn't want
to conform by getting you know i i
didn't want the degree
the the um the job the mortgage the
sitting in an office
i didn't want to go down that
conventional route that
that is why because i didn't
i didn't feel like a conformist i did i
didn't want to be a sheep i wanted to be
the shepherd i didn't want
to just conform to the expectations of
what society deems is successful
why because i'm just making sure you're
not playing
you're not you're not doing it just for
the sake of devil's advocate just to go
against
no not at all i'm not i'm actually not a
contrarian i'm not someone who says
left just because the other person has
said right i'm really not a concern if
anything
for someone who doesn't like criticism i
should probably stand back and therefore
i should sit on the fence and
become the sheep but i i'm i'm
you're gonna discover as we chat i'm a
ball of contradictions
yeah so so nothing kind of makes sense
um i just know
what i have learnt over the years but
for me
conformity maybe i was stripped of that
just by the fact that i couldn't conform
when it came to exams so i couldn't
conform to what the
what the system wanted me to conform to
and therefore i wasn't going to conform
when it came to other things i wear
shorts all year round i'm not
you know i stopped wearing a suit ages
ago i kind of
slowly as my confidence has build has
built
i've found myself straying even further
from conformity
i think i'm going to end up one of those
ridiculous kind of english eccentrics
wearing a bow tie
you know you know the one like walking
around with a cat stroking it
because i kind of that that's how there
is
this kind of there's an enemy that i
have never
i still haven't really fully found but i
knew i wouldn't find
that person sitting in an office on a
computer
in a job that society expected me to
take
just so that i could follow the
narrative and the narrative being as
i've kind of explained
you know getting a good job that you can
then
um get a promotion you get the the good
wage you might get a bonus
you can buy your house you can get your
car you marry you get the dog
you have the children and then you
end up retiring and then you do all the
things you want to do and here's the key
because is it the journey or the
destination
so for me it's 100 the journey yeah yeah
so many people don't see that but you
should
but this is where you and i have quite a
lot in common okay we're
maybe what we're doing now in life is
very very
different but the fact that you will
suddenly just wake up one day and go
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna resign from
yeah
honestly it sounds everything you're
saying like i want to make this about
you but i feel like i've been on the
same journey as you're saying with the
you know one day you might have the dog
and whatever which is just trying to get
closer and closer to who i actually am
and um trying to find the courage the
strength to
um not allow society to write
to tell me what my how my story has to
be yeah so who's and this is the thing
isn't it whose story is it
yes is it yours or someone else's of
course it's someone else's story and it
was written
at another time in another age if we're
talking about marriage and these
constructs in our society for someone
else in the circumstances they lived in
and they probably weren't happy anyway
so to think that that same narrative and
storyline would be
would equal happiness in stephen
bartlett's life in 2021
is uh you know probably patently false
like
but don't you find this strange i'm not
going to don't i'm not going to tell the
whole thing although i'd be quite happy
to because i think you're a fascinating
person but
it is strange isn't it that archer i
don't think you have you know yet okay
so
so i've got two young children aged 10
and 11. so
obviously i'm really aware of the system
that they're now in that
failed me and i'm really nervous about
that fortunately i married someone who's
really intelligent
and has the thickest skin you'll ever
meet on anyone in the world so actually
my children are pretty resilient
much more than i was and i owe all that
to my wife but
i digress if you think about it it's
still a strange thing that
children are expected from the age of i
don't know four or five
to go off to nursery and then to school
where they're in a classroom with four
walls it might have a window if you're
lucky
you've got some teachers that may or may
not be really invested in their job i
don't want
that to sound disparaging to all
teachers because i know a lot of
teachers put a lot of hard work in
but it's still a gamble as to whether
you're going to get those that are just
doing it for the job or those that are
really passionate and driven and then
it's just
about ticking those boxes isn't it get
the exam grades
that the government have set so that
they can then go look hurrah we're doing
a great system yeah gcse grades are all
up
a level grades are all up it's all
looking great look at the number of
people going to university and i'm like
hang on
what is this expectation that everyone
should go to second
to further education to university it's
not i get people calling me or
emailing me getting in touch with me on
social media saying how could do you
think i should do a
degree in filmmaking and in broadcast at
university i'm like no
get an apprenticeship job if i could do
that i'd take on apprenticeships
no work your way get experience
and uh and and it just i find it really
odd that in 2021
we haven't changed this is a model yeah
i
i i did a tv show called um called
secret secret teacher with channel 4.
and i was i had the same bewilderment
about the education system and what how
it was incentivized for grades and
league tables and not
based on the child's like intrinsic
passions and who they want to become
because obviously
for me i was running multiple businesses
in the school all the school trips had
done all the vending machine deals so
our school made money from the vending
machines
and yet i was kicked out because i
wouldn't go to health and social care
and
push a plastic baby around the school
like i wasn't interested in that
so like the school viewed me as lazy but
really if you think about it the school
was lazy for not taking the time to
understand who i was
at that age but in filming that show i
learned something very valuable about
how the whole system works so i went
inside the school got to sit down with
the head teacher and i was like
how does this system work and he said um
the better the grades we get
the more students come to the school and
we get paid per
student so he gets uh let's say four
thousand pounds from the government per
student that they have
so his whole incentive is grades
grades grades grades and it's just like
a business they have customers
and the more customers they get the more
money they make and then as it as you
got the
you know the the institutional lad or
whatever universities are the same the
more they send to university the better
their
their rankings if their rankings are
good more parents will choose that
school
it's a business and it's incentivized by
money at the heart of it
and if at some point you could take the
money out of the system um then you'd be
able to fix it but that poor head
teacher he was the ceo and he said
i won't be able to buy pencils if we
have
a hundred less students come next year
so we better be on that league table
um and then i realized what was what was
wrong with it you know these are good
meaning people incentivized badly
yeah um and it's ha and it's how we
change the system though
you know because that's this is where i
could turn the tables on you and go
listen you've done these incredible
um startups you've been incredibly
successful
and i i know there have been a couple of
entrepreneurs who have attempted dabbled
in the school
uh model and how do you do it it's kind
of obvious to me one of the problems is
that there's
so many children how do you make it
financially viable to give everyone
access to um you know
a a a fair education for them
and to to have bespoke systems for every
single pupil
cost a lot of money but i in the same
way as i'm talking about apprenticeships
you know i'm a keen advocate of like a
national service not a military one
but i think everyone aged 18 should go
off and spend
a month with the nhs with the fire
service with the police service
um just volunteering to see what maybe
working in the school system
and and if you imagine now that if if
all parents got invested in the school
and
volunteered to go in and help with the
classes
and help paying for different things i
just think
our education our education system could
be in a different place
i completely agree yeah i think it's um
i've i i did say when i left social
chain that the challenge i'd take on
would be the education system
so who knows let's see but uh i i came
to learn that it's like anchored in
place from all angles by parents
who believe that success for them as a
parent means their kid going to
university so my mum was disowned me
because
it made her look bad that i left the
system then you haven't but culturally
for lots of people it is still
really really really important my mother
is african so yeah she left school at
seven years old
and all of my friends who live
in various countries in africa or or in
latin america
it is or india it's still to to have
further education and by the way
obviously
to have further education for vocational
work like being a doctor or an engineer
you know we we really rely on on all of
that but
i think we have to change our attitudes
because can you imagine stephen this is
what
i find really shocking i i work with
people now
who are um working on production who've
left university with
40 grand of death and they're now and
they're scrabbling to
pay that back and get a job in the world
that they want to work in in this
post-pandemic or
middle of pandemic um world that we're
in right now
i mean that cannot be a good way to
start your life kind of in debt
is that not part of the system and it's
so unnecessary
i mean you what you spoke to everyone
about internships for me
is is the answer getting experience
right however that might be
and at my company we employed 700 people
at the time that i left
and i couldn't tell you who had a
university education or not it just
it was such a low down on the list of
things that actually mattered number one
is obviously
what are they capable of in terms of
experience um and then
the piece of paper i did i didn't have a
[ __ ] clue
who had gone where or what they'd
studied because it just doesn't matter
in reality
um but anyway i wanted to ask you get
back to one of the points you said
earlier you said um
you don't think you'll ever you're not
sure if you'll ever find
out who you really are could you expand
on that
what do you mean well i think we're all
the
the product i suppose of our experiences
and who we are
and and i think if you look at if you
look at
life as this journey and not just a
destination then
we're constantly evolving and changing
and
and growing and i think however much you
try to be yourself you
you become a bit chameleon-like and and
you end up
you end up kind of the lines between who
you are and
what everything else is does begin to
blur a little bit
so the way i look at it you know i
started off as this
deeply unconfident shy child that then
kind of
morphed into you know how i started when
i was on
one of the first reality shows which was
called castaway i was
sent to live on an island for a year and
then i kind of became
this posh real reality show
contestant and then i started working in
daytime tv
and i became a daytime tv presenter and
then i kind of became a broadcaster
and and you're i see it all the time you
become stereotyped so you whenever
when whenever your name is is written it
will say
you know it will have either an amount
that you made
or it will have the company that you
started but is that really
is that really you so so if you or i
went on strictly come dancing now by the
way that would be changed instantly and
it would then be stephen from
strictly come dancing or ben because
you're only
you're as you're remembered for the last
big thing
and that constantly changes but it then
means it's quite hard to
leap away from that so if you're
suddenly going to decide actually i'm
going to become a
an mp now people be like well hang on no
no that's not the narrative and what
happens i i
think what happens is you you become
blinded by people going i'm just not
really sure this is right because that's
not
that's not really who you are that's not
part of the narrative that
i think you were going down for the book
that you're writing of your life and i
don't mean
the physical book but just the
metaphorical one so
speaking of books yes in my book i have
a chapter called resisting your labels
and it's exactly this exactly what you
said so i refer to it as your label
and i say that your your label comes
with a set of instructions
implicit instructions about how you have
to behave going forward so my labels
would be
i don't know black social media ceo
and with that comes a set of
instructions as to how i'm expected to
pave in the future
and that can be imprisoning right so one
the reason i wrote that in the chapter
is because leaving social change i have
that same like existential moment where
you're like
okay so who the [ __ ] am i you know and
society's going
you'll be safest if you just [ __ ]
carry on with the social media ceo thing
yeah but at my heart i'm like no i'm i
no one was born with a passion for
something that didn't exist when i was
born social media
i'm a guy with a bunch of interests
music and creating stuff and
curiosity and how do i go back to those
fundamentals for my life and not the
label
yeah well i'm i'm slightly obsessed with
the label because
society loves to label us and uh and and
it's
and you'll never get away from that but
you i say you would never get away from
it
it will always be there in the context
of social media
and the the print press and and
um broadcast journalism but you can
i have tried to challenge the status quo
a number of times with
different things that i have done in
terms of
challenges um and other things the the
problem is that
i did so many of those challenges to get
away from just the daytime tv presenter
or just the reality show person that
then i became the adventurer who
does those things and the expectations
you know whenever
when i climbed everest two years ago
part part of the disappointment was
people going
oh yeah of course you'll do it of course
you'll get up but that's what you do
yeah of course you'll get up the
mountain i'm like it's not quite as
simple as that that's
you know i'm not a natural mountaineer
you know this is the boy who was
hopeless at sport it's still a
tremendous challenge but i i love
i love just testing failure
because i'm deeply fearful of failure
because of having so much of it
in in my early childhood you know just
to to back up
some of the data i've already given you
about how hopeless i was as a child you
know i ended up going to about five
different schools i actually went to
three different universities in the end
um uh took my driving test eight times
so it kind of it failure became
a really a word that i was really
fearful of
and and as i get older i find myself
actually
kind of um i find myself
confronting failure on purpose as much
as i can
to to try and become less fearful of it
i think you have to confront your demons
believers or not and
and failure so if we go back
to the challenges for example um because
they're one of the things that
kind of have really defined me you know
i somehow managed to row across the
atlantic ocean
i should have i should have quit there
really you know 49 days in a little boat
you know for for those who never saw it
it was a 20-foot rowing boat you know a
couple of oars
me and an olympic rower and it's pretty
dangerous out there it's the middle of
the atlantic ocean you've got waves that
are
30 feet tall where our boat got capsized
we nearly drowned we hit you know
it was the most amazing adventure but
also pretty scary and quite dangerous
and i did that and reaching the other
end of that
is still probably the biggest
achievement of my life and you know a
lot of my wife sometimes says why do you
not just quit there
because quit while you're ahead same i
could say to you
come on you've you did this amazing tech
startup
uh and i think a lot of people would
think that you've made all this money
just sit and enjoy it but but that's not
but then you're just taking life like
the destination
and you're thinking that well there you
are so money is everything and
and money i think money is a really
fascinating thing for me because
i am not money motivated i know people
may go well you can only say that when
you've made enough money to not be
motivated by money
and they have a point money buys
security
money gives you the opportunity to do
some of these big challenges i'm a
i told you there's lots of
contradictions here um and i'm aware of
all of those things but
we also live in a world by where success
is
defined by your monetary
value so when i you know if i google you
and i look you up
every single one has a sum of money of
various values right next to you so it's
next to your buyer so
listen by the way i think it's something
you should be really proud of if you
have if you have managed to make that
that much money i think that is that is
your everest that is testament to
dreams that lots of people have but i
think we need to change this notion that
being wealthy is a sign of success in
life
if you if you look at the model that
jacinda adam was trying to do in
in new zealand it was to change gross
national um
product to to change what the country's
values are by including the happiness
index
and the kindness index and how what what
a good
nation you are and how healthy you are
and your obesity levels
you bring into all of those things
because for me as a parent
i want my children to have the security
of having enough money to put food on
their
plate and a roof over their heads but
whether they make
huge amounts of money is kind of
irrelevant as long as
they are good rounded kind
happy individuals yeah i think you've
never known that this is actually why my
book is called happy sexy millionaire
because
when i was 18 all i wanted in life was
to be
as it says in the front page of my diary
range rover sport a million pounds
before i was 25
because i was it's the same similar to
what you've described the thing that had
invalidated me as a child
was being the only poor family
in a middle class area and never having
anything no birthdays no christmases and
everyone on holiday
so obviously that was my insecurity and
i chased it as an adult
and then i got it and then it you know
but by the way just
to reiterate i i think to have a goal
like
that is so important whatever your goal
is i'm just saying i think
to to have the the pure monetary goal
maybe isn't necessarily for for everyone
now for children
shouldn't necessarily be the priority it
can be a it can be a byproduct of being
successful
you know when i'm sure you get the same
thing when when i go and give talks in
schools and i go say what does everyone
want to be when they're older you know
i get a large number who just want to be
famous
and and i always say to them that's it's
all very well i i get why you want to
be famous but there needs to be
substance to that
fame so you need to be famous because
you have succeeded in business because
you're a great footballer because you're
a great
actor or actress and uh and and then
as a byproduct of all of that you can
become a great millionaire and
and um and and sort of
reach those dreams as well yeah so again
exactly what you've just said there
i think there's a the distinction for me
is like whether the goal was
intrinsically or extrinsically motivated
and the kid there that says he wants to
be famous is pure
is actually saying i would like people
to like me i want admiration
my goals as when i was younger were
clearly i want to fit in
i wrote millionaire but what i meant was
i'm insecure and i want to fit in
and obviously upon reaching that goal
because it wasn't ever intrinsic it
wasn't ever something that i wanted
inside of me
it was just to try and satisfy the
approval of others it felt like nothing
one of the things that's integral to
performing at the highest level is
nutrition it's something that i
i i guess i took a a long time to
finally believe but
that is why having hewlett's response
for this podcast is such a privilege
because
there was a time in my life especially
when i was early in my business career
where i wasn't getting the vitamins the
minerals and i wasn't having a sort of
nutritionally complete diet i was
if you look at some of my old photos i
was definitely lacking protein as well
and a lot of that maybe it was an excuse
was because
i was um i was busy and
when i discovered huel when a guy called
mike walt passed me in the office
wearing a heel t-shirt and shaking a
little bottle and
you know upon my curiosity of asking
what was in that and why he was drinking
it
it really really did change my life it's
almost religious my love for your but
for good reason
and if you haven't checked it out i
would um i would employ to check it out
because it's only going to do good in
your life
when you asked asked me earlier about
whether i believe the journey or the
destination
i just don't think the destination
exists every time you get there it moves
off into the distance like a mirage
yeah because as soon as you've got that
car you'll want the better car
as soon as you've got the house you'll
want the house in the south of france
so we're constantly changing our goal
posts because we we
i think it's human nature you know the
grass is always greener
i think of all the sayings i really do
think that is the one we
all look at other people and and social
media is a fascinating
medium now isn't it because effectively
social media one of the reasons i think
it's having
such a negative impact and when i say
social media you know the the
kind of twitter instagram why i think it
can have a lot of
negative impacts on people is because
it's
it's almost it makes people feel jealous
because people are projecting
uh it's i don't want to use the word
fakery but
it's it is an edited world isn't it
however whatever photo you do it's a
it's
a tiny second of your life that you've
thought about how you're going to
compose that photograph
or the image that you want to project
how you're living
and uh and i think that is all built on
this notion
of of wanting what other people have but
it's even worse because then you get
ranked on it yeah likes comments yeah
and then and then you know you post
you post a certain photo and then the
likes are down half and you think oh my
god i'm [ __ ] ugly
yeah you think the world can i put my
hand up
and honesty i i feel the same i i i'm
you know someone who's 47 you know i
should i should know better now but i
still look at
uh my instagram accounts and and if
there aren't so many likes or if
there's one negative comment amongst
hundreds of really positive ones
i just look at at the either the low
figure or the
the negative comment because i think
it's human nature that we're kind of
we're drawn to this this sort of
um this notion of competition
and is life a competition i i i kind of
wrote about this
at length and um i've realized that
value is
um obviously just relative so the
analogy i get i gave was that
i was really happy with my nokia 3310
but in a world of iphones
i'm devastated to own a nokia 3310 it's
the same [ __ ] phone
and they have these um really remarkable
studies that show
how we attribute value value to things
including ourselves where they'll put
like three stakes on a menu
and um if there's a really expensive
stake in a really cheap one everyone
picks the middle one
three tvs on a shelf people pick the
middle tv because they think that one's
too expensive that one's a piece of [ __ ]
and they're just using the context
are you in my head now because this is
exactly what i would this is yeah yeah
yeah exactly so and
i might but it's just we a trip we
attain value by the context we see
something in
if you remove the other two tvs this now
becomes the best tv in the world
and it's the same with us i said you
know in a world where there's no other
humans i am the prettiest richest
most successful person on earth but you
put a couple
and this is the crazy thing about social
media you're comparing yourself to
fake like a fake context and
and you you can never win right because
you get to see your bts you're behind
the scenes you look at them you think i
got spots
and i'm fat what's that pouch down there
and no one else has got that
so it's a losing game and and so i
implore people but you know because i
work for 10 years in this [ __ ] game
so
i implore people just to make their
context way healthier and real
um and for me that means that i meet 95
percent of the people i follow
i have like if i go on my instagram now
there'll be 15 people
and five of them are in this room do you
know what i mean
because i just want to play this game
and even though i'm aware of it
my lazy ceo brain has been wired
from the for 10 000 years to make snap
judgments
snap judgments to keep me alive i can't
stop it
you know so i just have to be conscious
about the way i use these tools
yeah i mean i think it's a it's a
fascinating world and again as a father
with young kids who are terrifying
embarking into that world
i i i'm struggling to find the tools
to arm them for the battle ahead yeah
and
i'm aware that they can be fantastically
useful that you know that
it's amazing the the interactions that
you can
get you know is it's it's how i'm here
today i wouldn't be here
if it wasn't for uh social media
chatting to you now so i i'm aware of
the beauty of being able to share things
it's just how we get away from
kind of the the fakery if if that is the
term to use
and and the abuse you were talking about
a second ago negative comment one
negative comment can throw you off
mm-hmm
the kind of the the whole world of
trolling
fascinates me because deep down i just
know that those people that write
the nasty comments sometimes aren't even
real
sometimes they're just disgruntled and
it's probably no different to
how life would be in a pub there would
be some person in there that would go
muttering under their breath the problem
is on social media it get
it gets kind of brought to the surface
and
for whatever reason i think we probably
know newspapers
love to then regurgitate what that
single
individual spotty teenager in their
bedroom
has written uh as a as
validation they sort of validate it so i
i had a
funnily enough during the first lockdown
my daughter thought it would be nice to
get the nation to sing happy birthday to
the queen and
i realize there's lots of people who
aren't monarchists i understand that
we're
in a country where not everyone agrees
on the same thing but i thought it was
quite a nice sentiment
and foolishly i decided to let her use
my twitter account to kind of ask people
to do it
big mistake we got death threats and
worse
uh i mean the vile abuse to my
nine-year-old daughter partly my fa
you know i shouldn't have allowed her to
i shouldn't have
shared this idea in a social
um media platform with a g with with my
daughter i realized
but i was amazed at the vile vitriolic
abuse and that was partly
kind of enhanced by the press who jumped
on
a few negative comments wrote about it
and as soon as they had written about it
uh it went i mean it i had to give up
twitter i actually
um abandoned it and haven't i haven't
gone back to really
crazy there's a lot of talk at the
moment about
what social platforms can do for this
type of behavior and i just
i always come back to the point of like
i'm gonna tell a little bit of a story
here
so when i worked in silicon valley for a
little while for about a year when i was
20 after i left my first company
and i got to see behind one of the big
social platforms that was emerging at
the time
and it taught me something about humans
because someone in the daytime who was a
very civilized school teacher
just being completely honest would get
his [ __ ] out at night
because of anonymity and what it taught
me was that people
good people are capable of pretty
alarming things
if you allow them to cover their face
and there's a piece of jealousy and
evilness and darkness in all of us
um and anonymity allows you to be both
yeah and so
until platforms don't allow people until
we verify people who people are when
they sign up
and there's no and there's no real and
there's real world consequences of the
behavior
it's never going to stop yeah and i
agree i agree it's the anonymity thing
so you know the number of people that
say just get up just just
ignore it and i do largely so i still
use instagram
and occasionally you know the odd troll
flares up and i do ignore it now
um occasionally you know i get a bit
more stung than
than other times but i think you know
it's symbolic of the world that we're
we're living in right now and i think
anonymity can be quite a dangerous thing
wokeness wokeness woke wokeness is
fascinating
wokeness is it's fascinating and it's
really complex now especially as a
documentary maker
i go off to to
countries all around the world and and
i've been accused of
of um gross xenophobia
just because i go to these countries now
and
maybe make a documentary about a local
group of people who live there
it's seen by the extreme woke brigade
as being as other ring people this is
the this is the woke
term right now don't other people so
by by taking a document i know it i mean
it is laughable but they're quite but
they have quite a strong voice
and and i've you know i've had to talk
about this on
other people to other people is to make
them
feel like they aren't a part of
normal i mean this comes we've come full
circle right now so
other ringers to make people um kind of
feel
like they don't like the specimens or
something yes specimens basically so to
other
so effectively going if you imagine you
know going to a group
of indigenous native um
uh people who live in the brazilian
amazon where once that was seen as you
know
anthropological study of how people
live and what they do now it's seen as
sneering and laughing at people because
you're othering them and you're showing
look look at them still hunting with
spears and bows and arrows
now this is the wokery brigade who
interpret it like that i interpret it as
a great celebration
because more often than not i kind of
been seeing how we should be living and
how we should
be um treating nature and the flora and
fauna around us
rather than living in big cities where
we're fantastically wasteful and we're
destroying the planet
actually the the this kind of nomadic
way of life or this very simple hand to
mouth way of life i
i go and i i feel i feel huge
admiration and i'm not laughing or
sneering but there are lots of people
that
interpret that form of television as
that now i've just given you one form of
vocary right now and there's is
so we all have to we have to think about
everything we say
and everything we do and is that
cultural i've just got a kilt
i've been sent a kilt because
it's the big global climate conference
in glasgow later this year i'm going to
be up there in
scotland obviously the kilt is is the
national dress
and i was asked if i could wear a kilt
with a special environmental fabric so
i've agreed to do that
but i can already see when it comes to
that culturally
that by the way i'm a quarter scottish
as well but i'm not even going to try
that because it wouldn't it wouldn't get
past the woke
police because it's cultural
appropriation i was going to say if you
went to the
amazon jungle and you saw that tribe and
you showed up with a spear
and a skirt but you know if
so if you look at what bruce parry used
to do where he would immerse himself and
he would live there i don't know if you
remember bruce perry
he would go and live there for there
being
with a a group of with a tribe somewhere
and he would adopt their native dress
whether it was just a little
you know whether it was a very simple
skirt whatever it was
and he would live as they do i don't
know if you could get away with that now
because it would be seen as a mix of
cultural appropriation
othering people um and it should be
we we should leave people to live as
they do
without trying to mimic it that's that
that's how it is
interpreted by some people where is all
of this wokeness going because i feel
like it's gaining momentum
and i i worry about the trajectory i'm
like it's not is it going to come back
this way because it's been i feel like
society has swung in a work direction
maybe because of social media it's kind
of like reinforcing reinforcing all of
us on our echo chamber
yeah that's perfect you're perfect that
was good good you're bad bad
that's bad he's bad get him but surely
you know this
probably more than than i do that you
have extreme wokery on one side
but then we have the extreme we've got
kind of fascism
and the complete opposite yeah on the
other side
and that 4chan and yeah and that whole
world
is is equally
more obnoxious yeah the racism the
xenophobia
and then you've got walkery here and
it's just like everything else in life
it's everything has gone
like this so you're either in or you're
out you're up or you're down it's black
or it's white
it's there's no middle and for
everything i've just said to you about
not wanting to be the sheep
and wanting to be the shepherd i i'd
quite like to just be a sheep amongst
quite a few others
in a field kind of having a reasonable
conversation it's very very hard to have
a sensible conversation now because
people
have gone to these extreme sides
it's probably easier for the newspapers
to write stories and to highlight the
workery
than it is to do the fascism because
that's really ugly and
and it's deeply offensive to so many
people but we see it you know
we know it's on social media you see
what's happening to footballers the
racist abuse that they get
and we do read about it but the wokery
for some reason is something we hear
about even more and maybe it's used
to try and counterbalance the really
ugly side of racism and xenophobia
and and anti-semitism all these things
that are equally
rising um and i don't know how we get
back to this
middle just being a sheep in a field
because i i
you know i long for a good solid
conversation i
i can't sit at a table now with people i
don't know really really well and have a
conversation about covert
because that's politicized i can't have
a conversation about politics
because that's that that went ages ago i
can't have a conversation about brexit
i can't have a conversation about indie
ref 2
i can't have a conversation about what's
happening in northern ireland
i can't really have a conversation about
international policy and
by the way i have more interesting
conversations and just says these
i am actually quite fun sometimes but i
really like debate and i like hearing
what other people have so when i travel
to other countries
my favorite thing is chatting about
their interpretation of what's going on
and
and uh and i really thrive on that but
we can't anymore because it's become too
emotional
people feel it's really personal to them
or they're too afraid to talk about it
in the first place
you talked at the start of this
conversation about not wanting to be
imprisoned by society's conventions
this is a form of imprisonment isn't it
of course yeah and it and it and it
which is maybe one of the reasons why i
still find myself drawn to
far away places so the show that i do
new lives in the wild where i go to live
with people
who've dropped off the grid they've
they've woken up one day and they've
decided
i i don't want this life anymore
sometimes they're millionaires
sometimes they're just everyday folk who
have
got bored of the nine to five job and
they've gone to live in the jungles of
bali in a little cabin in alaska
and uh and i really covet their lives i
really admire their lives i'm really
jealous of their lives because
they've simplified it we're living we
make we've made our lives pretty
complicated haven't we really if you
think about it oh yeah
um and actually if you strip it back
what do you really need in life will we
you know you need shelter you need food
you need water
some good company we've really realized
that with the pandemic i think people
have realized
that we're social we need to have
friends and family around
you need a smile on your face and that's
kind of it
and everything else it's a distraction
or it's an extra bonus
isn't it you know to to you know have a
fine wine
or whatever it is you like in life
but all these people that i've spent
time visiting i've done this series for
10 years now and i've been to 100
places um all around the world that
simplicity
is is really attractive and they don't
worry themselves about
those big topics i was just you know
describing there
it's it's kind of unimportant to them
what happens with brexit doesn't really
matter
for the person that's chosen to live on
a tiny little island up in
norway who lives hand-to-mouth catching
fish each day
and there's i i've i find it really kind
of hypnotic and mesmerizing
to spend time with people who have
stripped their lives back to the
absolute
bare essentials and the assumption is
that
that they're really enduring and they're
suffering and they're
surviving but that's not always the case
sometimes
it doesn't mean their lives are easy but
almost all of them are happy almost all
of them have have abandoned the
complexities that many of us are
stepping around they don't have to deal
with walkery and trolls
you know all these things are very first
world problems although they're not
actually they're
the the the developing or the lesser
developed world i should say
um i suffer from all of these um
these things as well i was on a uh to
speak to the point you just met i was on
a
motorbike like a little crappy motorbike
in bali don't know two weeks ago
and i'm just bombing down the street in
the field
sunshine walk going through the little
villages and i had this like real
overwhelming sense that i'd lived my
life wrong
and i got off the bike and said to my
friend and it's so crazy and
i don't think me and him will ever
forget this moment before i could say
the words to him
he went god isn't that what life's about
and it was just being on this bike
having no problems no care in the world
but also seeing a culture where they
also they live
in such a simple manner that made me
reflect on the decisions i was i've made
in my life
and it's such a remarkable thing as you
say those people are typically their
lives aren't easy but they seem to be
much more at peace than
the successful first world quote-unquote
people
well there's there's a great kind of
story that's kind of hypocritical but i
suspect it's true
a tourist goes to west africa let's say
they're in senegal they're on a
beautiful beach staying in a hotel
he he's on the beach every day and he
sees a fisherman go down and cast his
line over the story
it catches a few fish and uh and after
the week he goes to him and says listen
i think
why don't you invest in a second rod so
that you can catch twice as many fish
and then you can sell twice as many fish
and then eventually get a net and then
you can get a boat
and then you can start selling dozens
hundreds of fish
thousands of fish and earn even more
money so that one day you can retire
and do what you want to do and the man
who's fishing says what
fish and i just i just think there's a
lot to be said in that
because it's about chasing these goals
and and what your goal is
and and i think if we too many people
are kind of blinded by and again coming
full circle this notion of life is a
destination
and eventually you're going to reach
this nirvana this this this
glorious place where everything's
perfect where
you you just lie around i don't know
everyone has different things they dream
obviously you know someone just wants to
go and play golf i have no idea why i
don't know
but someone just might want to play golf
all day someone might want to play cards
all day someone just might want to just
move to the south of france and sit and
drink beer all day someone might want to
go surfing all day
whatever it is but there's no reason why
you can't
be doing that throughout your life you
just have to think outside of the box
don't you
you just have to have this positive
attitude and you know this comes back to
what i was saying to you as a child i
realize this if you think you're going
to fail you're going to fail
so every driving test all of those ones
i told you i failed
i would get in the car and this booming
deafening voice was saying you
are going to fail and sure enough i'd
mount the pavement
all right i got stopped by the police
once because i wasn't wearing a seat
belt yeah on a driving test
but because it was almost like
self-fulfillment
of my mind's attitude and it was only
actually working with olympians that
i've done now when i climbed everest i
went with victoria pendleton the cyclist
when i rode the atlantic it was with
james cracknell
and i've been lucky enough to work with
some other olympians that i realize you
need this
absolute confidence verging on arrogance
that i
will get to the top of this mountain i
will
reach the south pole because as soon as
you go into an event where you're
there's any self-doubt it's it's it
it will be self-fulfilling you must know
that you you yes you know that
but it's like it's a fake in my view
like i i
really i'm i'm quite repelled by this
culture of like
people looking in the mirror and saying
you are going to be a millionaire you
are great but d
because i my opinion of how beliefs work
like so i always use this example this
millionth time i've said this if i were
to hold your loved one at gunpoint now
and say believe i'm jesus where i kill
them
there's nothing you could do to actually
believe i was jesus
you could only lie to me because that's
not how belief works but as you've
proven beliefs take evidence
and you've built that evidence for your
challenges right so like just just
telling yourself to believe something
doesn't work even if
everything is on the line um but if i
suddenly turn this into wine and then
start levitating yeah you might think
wait wait a minute but this is but but
you're
you're taking it slightly too literally
when it comes
to what that is so here's the thing i i
th there's a man called mark boyle who
who um
lives in ireland a fascinating man i
think you should get him on here
he has lived as the moneyless man and he
gave up everything and tried to live
without
any money for a year and he ended up
with a with a house
is is what he did by trip by charming
trading up
uh literally just working his his way
through the system but never ever ever
using money
it was always trade and barter and
borrowing and i don't think there was
any stealing
not that i know of but i love this
notion that he had an absolute
confidence that
this would work and that he would be
able to do it
now with something like everest you're
right
you couldn't just take someone off the
street and say believe you're going to
climb this mountain and you're going to
get to the summit
because you need to do with the
acclimatization you have to get yourself
physically ready you have to understand
about
um high altitude and and you have to
understand the
the the basics of climbing at least uh
so you you're right but if you even with
all that
if you go into that arena as such
into the mountains with any doubt
it it's it it's going to be a
self-fulfilling prophecy that you won't
succeed so it's i think this idea of
belief that you can
you're right it's much more than just
looking in the mirror and going i'm
going to be the best musician in the
world
this comes back to school kids who
aspire for fame you know i think it's a
the kind of the x factor britain's got
talent has a lot
has a lot to answer for because it's
kind of made this illusion that
anyone can be whatever they want in life
now part of my whole
i i suppose part of of of the story that
i tell is that
that you can follow your dreams but i
always
give say that with the caveat it has to
be reasonable if you
if your dream is to be a top footballer
you're
but you have to be but if if you know if
if someone comes up to me and
a a youngster says i really want to just
be um a top footballer i want to play
with a premiership club
i don't see why they can't but there has
to be a there has to be a base level
of pretty brilliant football from a
start you said i mean of course so i
think you have to be realistic
with those aspirations if someone wants
to be a top
neuro scientist or a top doctor
i don't see why they can't but they have
to have it was going to be impossible
for me i wanted to be a vet
uh and i think i would have been quite a
good vet but i just didn't have the
academics so i didn't even get
off the start plate i think it's a
really important thing to
reiterate to people that i do believe in
that mindset
believe you can aunt middleton who's
been on here he's another keen advocate
of that
just believe in yourself this positive
mindset but the positive mindset has to
has to also um marry up with
ability and skill so i completely agree
with the um because i genuinely when i
think there's a butt coming here
yeah no so it's it's actually not a but
to your point
it's a it's a it's a question about how
to achieve this point because
i completely agree when i've been asked
um what my talent was i was like
can't spell can't do math still probably
dyslexic just never
gone to check um but i just always
believe that's what i've always said for
my whole life i always believed i was
gonna bit so think about what i wrote in
my diary
as a kid that didn't have a driving test
and his parents weren't speaking to him
with shoplifting pizzas
gonna be a millionaire within four years
gonna have a range over sports can be my
first car i didn't even
i and i genuinely believed it and for me
that was my
mother gift that life gave me was this
like low-key delusional belief
and that took me out and so when i was
living in moss side stealing pizzas and
stuff
i started recording it in my diary and
doing little videos
and it's crazy in the first page of my
diary i lied to my diary i said
i'm recording the these um this journey
because
a production company has asked me
to because like you lied to yourself i
lied in my own
because i i couldn't i i almost didn't
know how to say to my diary
that this was going to be part of a
story i was going to tell one day and i
and it's not that i'll share my diary
the first page of it it's like
because and and also because i think i'm
going to have to tell this story one day
that is a guy that saw himself
on an island and knew he was getting off
the island and wanted to
like wasn't dwelling on so i completely
agree i think the only reason i'm here
is not because of smarts
my parents were completely broke um
obviously i had privileges of being born
in this country
well born in africa actually but um it
was just that i always believed i'd be
here
however when i try and impose that onto
people and tell them the importance of
self-belief
and i see these people who have got
their confidence just absolutely in the
bin because of experiences they've had
or their dad when they were four years
old told them that they're a piece of
[ __ ]
and my fluffy words you know when
they're 35
aren't stronger than those words that
their dad said to them you know i
struggle to try and tell them how to get
to that place of genuine self-belief
because as i said you can't fake it if
stephen had a shred of doubt in moscow
i'd still be there
so like what do i say to that person
well it's the building blocks of life
isn't it it comes back to that so if you
you know the the series of challenges
and things that i've done in my life
have slowly built themselves up so i
started on that year on
living on an island in the outer
hebrides now if you strip that back it
was
it was pretty simple it couldn't really
fail it was hard work it was hard being
away from people no
no contact with the outside world no no
phones mobiles
family i didn't see anyone for a whole
year just this small group of people
well once i did that it was kind of
that was the fir that was like the
foundations i was like oh my gosh
well i've done this and then and then i
put the next block in which was running
the marathon day saab six marathons in
six days i'd never even run a hundred
meters stephen
and suddenly here i was agreeing to run
across the sahara desert
and i managed to get through that i came
last but i didn't manage to do it
and and these building blocks have just
gone up so when you
say to people you know when you're
trying to encourage as i do as well
people to
this self belief it has to be a
realistic self belief
to of the slow building blocks of life
if we come back to kind of
reality shows because i'm slightly
obsessed with reality shows and
and and this kind of what's happened
over the last 20 years
what it's done is it's given people this
belief that anyone can become
world famous overnight and and i've
already alluded to
britain's got talent x factor but big
brother love island all of those shows
because it takes
everyday folk and it catapults them onto
the front pages
of newspapers five million followers
overnight on social media and earning
quite a lot of money
but how long does that last for now for
many people you know it's the famous
andy warhol only 15 minutes
it doesn't last very long because what
happens is there's no substance to it
there's no roots and what happens is the
next show comes along
and they're cast aside but what also a
lot of people do is that they
the leap from one brick to the next is
too high and if you if you go too big
it's doomed to failure i remember
funnily enough i think
one of the reasons why me a reality show
contestant
is still working in tv after 21 years
because i should have my 15 minutes was
up a long time ago
i think the reason is more because of
the things that i turned down
than the things that i i agreed to do
so i turned down some pretty big shows
big prime time saturday night shows that
a lot of people who work in tv would be
like i would do anything for that but
the leap was too big and i didn't
believe that
i i think i i think the the um
even though i like to confront risks i
like to be realistic with those
so k2 is a far more dangerous mountain
than everest i could have gone straight
to k2 but
instead i want i want to do a
sensible building block up
to that ultimate challenge and i think
right back to television
i think if you if you if you take too
big a leap
then um the the reality of continued
success
um is eroded away when you think about
some of those opportunities that you
were given that you turned down
what was it about them that made you
think it was too big of a leap because
i'm trying to answer the question for my
viewer
which is how do i know if it's too big
of a leap i think you just have to be
sensible about what you're capable of
i think so it's this really fine line i
told you i'm full of contributions so
i'm telling you you know i'm sitting
here kind of saying to people follow
your dreams don't be told
that you can't do it nothing no dream is
too big
um you know believe in yourself and and
you're halfway there you know i really
do believe in all of that but you also
have to be sensible
so i think okay so here's the thing i
reckon
that i i'm the son of a an actress
and i believe that i could be an actor i
always wanted to be an actor i got
rejected by all the drama schools
by the way because i couldn't remember
my lines but that's a whole other thing
um but i still think i could be an actor
and and i have quite a confidence that i
could
but if i was suddenly offered a steven
spielberg film
yep i wouldn't take that now because
my ultimate goal is to try the acting
thing
at some stage in my life when it's
appropriate but i don't want to do it
on in such a big extreme explosion
of public ridicule if it goes wrong now
together with that i add this sort of
confidence that yes i will be able to do
it
but i'd prefer to start in a little pub
theater
with 20 people just on a smaller stage
and build up because there has to be
and i think we all have to agree with
this
as well as this confidence and this
self-belief
you have to have the skills yeah if you
don't have the skills there's just no
point and we're just being delusional
and it's no different to that instagram
fakery of of
of showing people this idyllic life when
actually that's just a tiny little one
second
of actually what was a really miserable
weekend because it was the only time the
sun came out and someone
you threw on a bikini i didn't throw in
a bikini you know you get my point
you know to show that instant moment of
of perfection
so i think there has to be um an actual
skill and you have to earn it
i think you know this this instant
gratification just doesn't exist
there is a few examples and you're
you're one of those where you were able
to
write down i'm going to be a millionaire
i'm going to have that range rover sport
and you did it and and you are what
gives so many people hope
but i failed mm-hmm i failed in my first
company
but it doesn't matter but but that
doesn't matter surely failure
if you haven't failed you haven't been
trying hard enough yeah do you think i
think
the the people who because i i
realized that quite early on if you
haven't if you haven't failed
at various points through your life then
then you're you're being too measured
with the challenge that you take which
is a failure
yeah which is a failure which is a
failure in itself yeah
yeah i i yeah so many of the things you
said there i was i was just
you know i was captivated but i was
wondering whether you're if you're
so you said you were a contradiction at
the start of this conversation
but then you've also alluded to the fact
that you like to to not be on either
pole
and you like to be like the sheep in the
field which actually probably makes
sense because
you can appreciate the need for ambition
but then you also appreciate the need to
have self-awareness
right so it kind of puts you in the
middle of the field well if you think
about it
it's a really weird thing because i'm
actually again true to the
to the contradictions you know the son
of an actress i've kind of got the jazz
hands and i quite like
talking and i like being on stage as
such but i'm also still
quite shy so i kind of like being in the
wings i want to be on the stage then i
want to be in the wings
and i want to be on the stage and and
the same goes
for kind of how i project myself so i
want to be part of the conversation but
then i don't want to be part of the
conversation i don't i don't like the
uncomfortableness of it i want to be a
politician but i i couldn't bear the
you know the the the focus and the the
um
the derision that you're going to get
from one side or the other
and i actually think once you've
accepted that because i think a lot of
people
i'm sure a lot of people are like that
really and once you've accepted that's
who you are
you just work out how to walk those
stepping stones and kind of move around
it and i kind of do this
i dance my way through it and dip in and
dip out and i have moments where
i kind of i wish i hadn't kind of uh
i wasn't on the middle of that stage but
i am so i own it
and it's it's back to this whole thing i
do i do believe
you kind of have to own your narrative
it's very easy to let someone else steal
it from you
i think i think i actually read that in
on the last page of the first chapter of
your book it said um
the ocean talk the ocean had taught me
to take control of my own narrative and
believe in myself
when you were talking about um what you
learned from the sea in your book
inspire the lessons from the wilderness
and that taking control of your
narrative point really stuck with me
um because obviously society writes your
narrative i had a major announcement
this week as you've probably all seen on
social media
or in the newspapers relating to a tv
show that i'm doing
and um it was just a great you know it's
a great example of the power of the
platformfiver.com because
i wanted to make this announcement using
using visual effects and visual effects
are typically staggeringly expensive
the quotes that i got back from agencies
were like 40
50 grand to make a very short 60 second
video in visual effects it was
staggering right
i wanted to show me turning into a
dragon um
and i used fiverr.com who were the
sponsor of this podcast and we made this
really cool short 45 second video which
shows me transforming
into a dragon check out the video go
check out fiverr.com
if you've never used it just the most
cost-effective way to get creative
services done i've used it for the last
three and a half years of my life
one of the things that i picked up a lot
of from listening to your interviews and
your books was
your about your relationship with your
lovely wife
and you're both very vocal about the
dare i say not radical but the sort of
like innovative way
that you've built your relationship in
various areas one of the really
interesting things to me was this idea
that you have
preventative marriage counseling
yeah tell me about that and why do i
need it so
so my so my wife marina we've been
married for
this will be our 15th year together wow
she's half austrian thank you she's half
austrian and she's
she's got skin like a rhino it's
unbelievable
uh as in can i just say that that
in terms of uh be not ever being
offended she's got
glowing skin her skin is really it's
really
she moisturizes the whole time
she doesn't have this big wrinkly grey
skin oh my god i'm blushing i'm going to
get in so much trouble for that
but she is she she's really tough she's
really resilient she's no nonsense she
doesn't beat about the bush
and we're very you know i i am by my own
admission a much more sensitive soul now
it doesn't mean she isn't sensitive
but but she's she kind of calls a spade
a spade
whereas i might say well that is a spade
but you could probably could use that as
a
could you do what i mean i kind of
because i want to please all the people
and i don't want to offend so i kind of
find myself kind of
dancing around a little bit in the
middle there you go whereas marina has
always just been straight down the line
and our
our kind of our relationship is has been
built on me being away a lot because
outside of the time of covid i'm
probably traveling eight months of the
year
so there's a lot of time away but that's
how it's always been
and we have a really solid relationship
and
and we we had a terrible tragedy about
um six years ago when we lost our third
child
a little boy willem who was stillborn so
he is so
three weeks before he was due to be born
naturally um
unfortunately marina had something
called a placental abruption
and he died and and it was an awful
awful experience that i've kind of
spoken about before
but it affected us profoundly much more
than i thought it would
that that the feeling that this emotion
of
losing someone you'd never had a chance
to meet is is something i'd never
experienced before
and i couldn't quite understand my own
emotions and and added to that when this
all happened
i was on the other side of the world i
thought marina was going to die so
it was a big very
impactful part of our relationship and
we sought counselling afterwards to help
us through
the complexities of all of those
emotions
and it was through that that we we kind
of realized that actually our own
relationship we
we talked about things that we hadn't
talked about before
outside of the the awfulness of that
situation we talked about
are very different characters and how
how we kind of
tread around one another and i think a
lot of a lot of relationships
have that they don't you you might joke
about your very different personalities
but there are certain areas that you
know oh no i can't ever say that i
couldn't do that
well why couldn't you you should be
really really honest the best
relationships are ones where you can say
anything to one another without fear of
offense now i've already said that i've
brought a thin skin so i'm easily
offended and marina has offended me many
times
over the years and i've offended her and
and i think
this this marriage counseling prevention
came was born out of that and about a
year afterwards marina
we were struggling a little bit it was
such a profound thing that it affected
us because we had different ways of
dealing with
with the grief of losing that little boy
marina
was was very tearful and then she'd be
totally fine she'd have big tears and
was fine
and mine i became really introverted and
and
and uh and i became really anti-social
didn't want to be anywhere i remember
going trying to go to big events i had
to go
to some big red carpet events and
literally just
arriving and just saying to the driver
just drive on i could i couldn't go
or i'd go to events and i'd find myself
going to the loo and just sitting
sitting in the little cubicle for the
duration of the whole event
parties i would find myself just
literally arriving
saying hello hello and then just
literally diving out the door because
i think it's because i couldn't control
[Music]
i couldn't control the the narrative
this narrative that i wanted to be in
control of i didn't know who was going
to come up were they going to talk about
my loss were they going to there were
there were things i couldn't prepare
myself for
and and those two very different
approaches and two very different um uh
kind of emotions that marina my wife and
i had
meant that it did create tensions so we
saw someone and
and she was the one that suggested that
once a year we just go and speak to her
as a preventative and you know it kind
of just makes a lot of sense
you know marina i've told you already
she's very straight laced and she's very
straight and she was like well why
wouldn't we
why wouldn't we just go and with someone
there say tell you what i do find really
frustrating it's when you
always do this or you always say that if
you do it in a home environment
the natural reaction usually it's going
to be over dinner probably had a drink
you're going to be even more emotional
and go i don't you'll become defensive
i i defy any relationship to say they
that that doesn't happen
but to do it with a third party who is
trained
to kind of be non-judgmental is a very
good way
of speaking to you via that person
without fear
of getting really emotional because
marina and i are also really
we do get really emotional we probably
argue once a year
but when we do it's massive
people may be surprised because we do
we're we're highly emotional and we get
it's really tearful it's not there's
there's no uh black eyes or anything but
it's a really
but you know we don't argue very well
and what we found actually was
that speaking to someone else once a
year has has i can't remember the last
time we had
an argument we really we haven't for
years and years now which is
saying something because i you know i'm
also all for honesty
you know in this world of of kind of
social media fakery i
i wear my heart on my sleeve and i've
always been really honest so
talking about the loss of willem talking
about my dyslexia but i think it's
really important that you're very honest
especially if you live in a very public
sphere
hearing that you've not had an argument
for years is a pretty
incredible achievement one would say in
a relationship
why how how why well i think it's part
i think the fact that that we speak to
the same person every year for only like
an hour or two twelve months apart
though yeah i know
but it's because it all come because i
think we we are
able to just be really really honest
right
there and then and and by the way i'm
that does i'm not saying
our relationship is really you know it's
not one of these
um wedding cakes perfectly formed
everything is
idyllic birds flying around chirping
it's like any relationship it's strained
and and and we get snappy at one another
but we've learned to resolve i think
conflict resolution
is there and i'm what you know i have
although
i kind of try to be i'm an optimist and
and i try to be smiley and happy as
a more often than not
i still wake up some days and i'm
feeling a bit under the weather
or i do just get out of bed the wrong
side and i know when
i'm a bit more snappy and marina now we
we have
we are armed with ways of saying to the
other person you you're a bit
irritable today you seem a bit miserable
you're not much fun to be around
we we can say that in a way that doesn't
the other person doesn't jump to a
defense game i'm not you're the one
that's annoying me
just i mean that it turns into that that
argument and i think if you
learn how to speak to one another and
that's what we have
kind of been armed with it it is just a
great way to
to kind of avoid those unnecessary
arguments listen some people
have really fiery relationships and they
thrive on it we've got friends that
kind of need that they have big battles
and flames
and then and then they make up and it's
all fine and i've got some friends i
just find that exhausting
yeah it's a mental health awareness week
this week
and um one of the things you said
earlier on about going to going to those
events and like
you know telling the driver to carry on
going or hiding in the toilet sounded
similar to you know shades of um
anxiety maybe even ptsd to some degree
um does is that what you think you were
experiencing at that time
were you anxious i was super anxious no
without doubt i um anxiety
um uh panic attacks you know
all of that happened for about a year i
experienced a lot of that
really i just just and i think it was
because i had lost control
i wasn't able to protect my wife i
wasn't able to protect that little boy
and i think my my the the
um reaction to that was to try and take
back control of my life and the only way
i could take back control of my life was
to control my environment
and and things were out of my control
when there were lots of people around
and i didn't know who i was going to be
talking to and about what and
where and when i was going to go away
and and
all the things that i'd lost control of
i wanted to regain control of and yes
anxiety definitely came into us and i'm
i've never suffered depression as i'd
call it but i have
every so often always coincides with the
full moon which is a bit weird but i i
get i get
what i just call the dark cloud and even
if everything in
my life is perfect i just have this kind
of
for a couple of days it does kind of
happen almost every month
just a couple of kind of gloomy days
when it's difficult to feel
happy and optimistic i don't think i
would define it as depression because i
think that would be demeaning to people
who really really suffer
from what is known as depression i have
lots of friends who
are suffering and have suffered from
clinical depression
but i think it's human nature you know i
i you know i
am an optimist i am happy most of the
time
but i also feel that little cloud of
of just darkness and it's and it comes
and goes and i can't i don't know when
it's there
um or why it's i know when it's there
sorry i don't know
um why it's there and then it it sort of
disappears and for me
sport has been my way so active
to be active has been my way um for
about 20 years of getting rid of that
has that always been
there has it always showed up no i think
it i think it probably showed up about
i'd say about probably just when i
started
in this business and the pressures i
think say 20
years or so i think it's it's it started
being there and it was
i i came quite late to kind of doing
exercise and it's not
bulging but i said that's not my kind of
form of exercise
but i went for a run just before coming
here oh you know so i
most days i will do something and it
just sets me up for the day
and it it keeps that cloud away
sometimes it's quite even that doesn't
work but i've got i've just got
different
different ways of of trying to kind of
keep the cloud
away super interesting really
interesting
really interesting so many questions to
ask within that i am
i have i've gone through my life i think
probably in the same
sort of optimism and you know generally
really happy but
you know i i do worry that uh
as the pressures of my life get more
intense that
you know i feel like i feel like when i
was growing up i thought mental health
was
was not a real thing and it was like
crazy people
and i was like well i'm happy i'll never
be and then i had i remember one day i
had anxiety for the first time and i
just couldn't understand it
but what it did for me was told me that
i'm susceptible to
everything health depression and all of
these things
um but yeah i mean it's good to hear
that exercise has been a bit of an
antidote
but the other thing we're coming back to
labels so a bit like i don't need
of course you know i've got dyslexia i
think
you know you might be able to go to a a
doctor and he might say yes i actually
did suffer a bit of ptsd
um but actually i think if you're strong
in yourself and you're strong in your
self-belief and you've got a good kind
of family dynamic around you you've got
a strong set of friends i think i think
you should be able to
navigate quite well if you learn the
tricks
of dealing with it and like i say for me
it has been um
a lot of reading i i love i i
read a lot about happiness um the the
there's a
great book um about happiness and i've
got a complete mind blank of the author
but he hypothesized about happiness is
it something that
um we're is it is it something to strive
for it's a bit like the destination or
the journey is happiness something we're
striving for are we work do we find
happiness
or is it other things that are
disguising the happiness
and and hampering it so if you think his
theory is that if you look at a child
children are by and large they might
they're going to be crying
if they've got a dirty nappy or they're
hungry or whatever but
by and large their emotion their default
emotion is
it's laughing think of children in a
playground yes they have little that you
know they their
tears come very easily but the default
is happiness and when does that start
eroding away kind of puberty and the
anxiety you know those anxious times of
when you're just you know when sexuality
is coming into your life all those
things
probably do start to affect that
happiness
but then moving on in life and this man
had done fantastically well made
millions and exactly like you were
saying about the cars
as soon as he made his first million
went out and bought his ferrari sat in
the ferrari and then was like
well yeah i've got it i've done it now
and now what
and and it was this constant aspiration
so the hypothesis is that actually we're
we're kind of adding apps almost things
to us that are making us unhappy
rather than striving for this happiness
thing because if we're
if if the happiness is the ferrari or
the million pounds
range rover sorry i got it wrong but if
but but if that is your
goal for happiness the human nature of
always wanting more
is going to mean you're constantly
searching for happiness and you're going
to have it fleetingly and then it will
go
and then you'll get it again fleetingly
and then it will go but actually if we
take away the things that are making us
unhappy
whatever that is social media get rid of
it
living in a big city get rid of it you
know you've just got back from bali
yeah i i saw a picture of you under a
waterfall i mean how how
but but tell like how happy we were you
in a nice warm place out in the jungle
in a waterfall listening to nature
all around you i'm gonna do something
now one second
so i actually wrote a little paragraph i
wrote a paragraph in my book about being
sat by the river in bali yeah i
described
the words of how i feel and it's funny
because the
chapter's called and i'm not plugging my
book here it just seems like it's the
best way
um the chapter's called the journey back
to human and the reason why the chapters
called that is because
i'm hypothesizing that i think we've
kind of lost our way
and being sat by this river in bali was
it felt like i'd come back to where i
was meant to be
here we go as i write this chapter i'm
sat at an indonesian jungle in bali
by a gloriously glistening river with
the unobstructed glare of the sun
overhead bearing down on me
there's this perfect light breeze stroke
in my warm skin and an earthy floral
smell
of the jungle surrounding trees occupies
my senses i came here to live in hubble
as i sit here and you may have
experienced this if you spent time in
nature i feel at peace as hysterics
might have described
i feel tranquil it's hard to explain
this in any other way than to say that i
feel like this is where i innately
belong
my primitive survival orientated senses
are often used prehistoric devices like
pain and discomfort as a usual way to
guide me away from danger and towards
safety seem to be telling me that this
is where i should be
the absence of discomfort and stress and
pressure
is telling me that this might just be
home and it's what you were saying there
about like
the removal so when you said did i feel
happy
the first thing that came to head was
like i didn't feel unhappiness there you
go right
so i didn't feel like there was no
notification but that is such a
fascinating
notion this idea that it wasn't you just
felt a default just yeah human you felt
just your tranquil the story yes they
use the word tranquil right
so all this noise that we get you know
we're here in central london right now
and when i say noise i don't just mean
the the
police cars and the ambulances and the
the pneumatic drills
i just mean all the all the things the
shops that are saying you should be
buying this
you should be getting that the
newspapers that are telling you about
other whoever your rivals are we all
have rivals
the the social media promise of someone
who's having a better time in
than you there's someone who's someone
else who's still in bali
when you're not there it's all these
things and i do
think they have a habit of making us
unhappy and it's weird isn't it because
we think that those are the things that
will make us happy
you know being on social media fishing
for those likes
the the um uh buying into the kind of
commercial world and trying to keep up
with the joneses now
that's where money gain coming back to
this that's why
money is seen by so many people as
the cure for everything because with
money you could go to bali you could get
the better car
but once you've got it as as you know
it's like well actually that was quite
fleeting
yeah and and this is funny because when
you look at the ways that we're
medicating mental health disorders now
um we went through this phase of
thinking that it was like a biomedical
problem so we would give people like
ssris and you know try and correct the
serotonin with these chemicals
and the more modern treatments all
seem to be trying to return us back to
probably what you go and see when you go
to the
the tribes that you you see in like the
amazon which is
human connection movement like we used
to hunt for our food not like [ __ ]
uber and delivery
um uh so connection with nature which
again
you know nature's therapy i mean this is
you know there's a lot of people who've
realized especially for mental health
you know
back to the mental health week there's a
lot of people who have seen
the the benefits of nature so in japan
and sweden for many many years now
they've
done something called forest bathing uh
and and forest bathing is
like many people do on the beach but
instead you just go into a woods and you
lie on the floor and you stare at the
canopy
and just imagine now i want you know
everyone who's watching this to just
imagine all those leaves
rustling in the wind birds you know
because once you stop
walking in a wood is so many people kind
of go we're going to go for a walk
and they just march through often have
headphones on
and it's like well you're not connecting
with that yeah you're just you're racing
through
but actually if you just sit there
animals start coming out you start
noticing colors you start noticing a
flower that wasn't there
and don't never underestimate the power
of that to just
reconnect us to you know where we're
supposed to be really we're not supposed
to be in big cities living in
apartments with your own um
you know with with running water and
things it's it makes it very comfortable
for us
but uh i think most of us really kind of
belong in a jungle in a woods on a
mountain
on the ocean closer to nature do you
know you hannah hari
do you know who that johann hari he
wrote called lost connection yes of
course yeah
he's going to be sat there in two hours
amazing he's coming and we always talk
about this
particular topic but yeah it's one of
the biggest revelations i had in my life
was that um
much of my ambitions were taking me
further away from like
being human so you know living in the
heart of new york city
um i could pretty much go through a
whole day without moving
ooh you know the uber picks me up takes
me to work takes me back home i use the
same glass screen to all of my food i
don't really see anybody because i lived
alone
uh and then you look at the stats and
you know new york is 30 times
30 more likely to be depressed than bali
or you know
something crazy like that but um yeah i
and as an adventurer and someone that's
spent time in nature
um i find it so fascinating that you've
you've you've come to the same
conclusion
about the true nature of happiness what
is your goal now though we talked about
there not being a destination when you
think about what your goal is
what is it i think again true to the
contradictions
i think we all need goals i think we
have to have something to aspire to
something to be working towards
but i don't have contrary to popular
belief i don't have a little black book
that says right okay we've done that now
i'm going to
cycle around the world and now i'm going
to climb this mountain
it's not like i just have a list of
things but
i'm kind of i try to live my life as a
yes man so i like to seize opportunities
i think the human nature default of no
to think about things uh really
carefully
is something i've tried to wean myself
away from and i tried to kind of say yes
to things
on a whim a little bit more so i think i
think
my goals are about continuing to test
myself
continuing to confront failure risking
what i do now given i've kind of got you
know i write books i
do tv presenting um
and i do adventuring um
i think i'd probably quite like to
find something else whether it's acting
whether it's politics
whether it's there you go i i'm
all for trying also yeah i'd love to
know if i have a voice maybe i'll become
a singer i'd love to you know
i wonder whether i could compete in the
olympics and is there any sport where a
47 year old could
like start from scratch and really you
know test themselves and and work
their way up to the sport there are a
few believe it or not i think that
we don't so i kind of i do have i kind
of think big
but i don't have absolute goals they're
not written there but i think
i think a bit like you were saying you
you would like to kind of tackle the
education system
i would like to make a difference
because i think the older you get you're
still
way too young stephen but the older you
get you start to question
why why have i done all these things
because if you think about if you just
break down
those big challenges that we've been
talking about it's quite egotistical you
know you climb on mountains hey look at
me
you you walk across a pole i get to come
and sit and chat to you
all about them and say how brilliant i
was but actually what what's the point
there has to be
more substance to why i did those things
and and more importantly
how i can um how i can translate those
into
something useful for other people so i i
would love to
again work on an education model work
with other people to
actually be able to start making a
difference because my life
up until now has all been about me it's
been about self
building about about building my own
self-confidence and that's
quite selfish and and i would like to
think of myself as a
or i'd like to be more selfless and i'd
like to do things for other people that
doesn't mean i haven't done
stuff and i've done a lot of charitable
things and philanthropic things over the
last few years but
i kind of feel i'm moving towards a time
when i really would like to focus on
um trying to improve the system
because if the likes of you and me and
other people don't do it
it's never going to happen we can talk
about it we can sit here and look all
smug kind of saying this is what needs
to be done and kind of nod our heads but
if you don't action it it will never
happen because politicians are just busy
doing their thing
and they'll they'll kind of just do what
they can
but they're never going to be able to to
to break
those glass ceilings that have been set
by previous
generations and i guess from what you
talked about
earlier about you know gradually picking
your battles
i guess you know you've done so much in
your career as well from everest to the
shows you've done to all the other
achievements you've had
that you're in search of an even grander
battle yeah i like i like a battle
but the battle doesn't have to it's not
a it's a battle within
it's it's not a you know this term of
of a battle i think some people think it
is um
it's against another person or against a
system
or against a belief or you're battling
against the trolls or the wokies or the
fascists but i i think the battles we
all have are the battles within
and i think as soon as you start
accepting that that's when we
will start kind of taking mental health
more seriously than we do because it's
really obvious to me that you know
that how your brain feels and how what
your brain is telling you
is is far more powerful than any kind of
broken bones that we have and it's kind
of weird isn't it that we still
you look at someone who's been in a road
accident oh poor you you broke your leg
you see that injury and we can relate to
it and we
we winced it but here what goes on
beneath the the skull is is deemed as
something kind of still
a bit taboo and it's not it's not really
taboo because people talk about it but
you still meet a lot of people who are
like nah it doesn't care it's no just
get
over it come on just just man up uh just
uh
you know just just believe in yourself
and you'll do it and as much as i'm
saying you need this
this um self belief it's far more
complex than that
it is and that's what makes giving
advice so difficult
right because you give it from the basis
of your own bias
yeah and advice is is bespoke
so i i could you know i get like i say
many people asking how can i
do x or y it depends on so many things
yeah and and and i can't really give
that advice it's a bit like a doctor
giving a prescription
i can't really give that unless i
genuinely know what your ability is
what your aspirations are what your
you know what what your mindset could be
all of these things come into it but if
we could start
you know helping people within that
context
i think we would be in a very different
place he's scared of dying
no i'm scared of i'm scared
for other people but i'm not scared of
dying which sounds really glib
i know but i genuinely am not and and i
don't know
why i've had many near-death experiences
maybe that has
i've had to i've had to look very
look at those clouds and think that i'm
i'm heading that way
quite a few times and maybe that is what
makes you less fearful when you've been
so close to it
but it's also perhaps that
i kind of i don't think i have many
regrets in life
i've kind of seized those opportunities
but i'm deeply fearful for those
i love um and and
the void that would be left which sounds
really kind of egotistical
but i know how much i feared about
losing my parents or loved ones when i
was a child
super interesting that idea that i feel
the same i'm i've
after i stopped being religious at the
age of 18 i um
i was actually scared of dying when i
was religious because i thought it was
going to go somewhere
right and then beyond that point um
gradually as i've achieved more in my
life i've got less scared of the idea of
i think well you know i've been true to
myself and that that seems to be the
most important thing as it relates to
and you you've referred to as regret
there have you got any regrets
not really not no because i've tried to
it's kind of one of the ways i've
tried to live life with no regrets and
you can you're only likely to have a
regret
let me change i was going to say you're
more likely to
regret the things you didn't do than the
things you did do but i know that's not
true i think plenty of people have made
made the wrong decisions we've all done
that but no in all seriousness
i don't think i i kind of i am an
optimist and i try to see the positives
in everything i've done and all the
decisions i've made and all the things
that have happened in life
and i i honestly i don't think
i can say that i regret anything
because it's the it's the old cliche
what doesn't kill you makes you stronger
and i think even those things that i
could maybe say well
probably wasn't the best decision
something good
has come of it there's gonna be so many
ben 18 year old ben
ben's listening to this right now who
listened to this and thought you know
what i'm really
low confidence and i've been knocked and
you know i'm not sure if i'm good enough
and i've been called a failure by my job
dad whatever it is
what do you say to those people having
walked
you know live their life what you say to
them what's the advice you give them
don't don't buy into someone else's
narrative
that's what you're doing by listening to
the failure whether it's absolute words
coming out of someone's mouth saying
well you're no good
whether it's whether it's even perceived
narrative
that you go into a pub and everyone
looks like they're having more fun than
you
and and the girl or the boy doesn't want
to be with you they want to be with
the other person i think i think you
just have to
own your narrative you are you in this
world of
what are we 6.7 billion probably got
that wrong but
in this world of many many billions of
people there is no
there is no other stephen yeah that is
fact
yeah there might be someone similar
there might be someone with the same
abilities the same body type maybe even
looks a bit like you but
you are completely unique because your
personality
um belongs to you and don't try and
change that don't try and be the person
that other people want you to be be
the person you are and it's it's it's a
really hard thing
to buy into because i spent so much of
my life trying to be the person
i thought society wanted me to be always
embarrassed that i wasn't i was either
too posh or i wasn't posh enough i was
either too successful or not successful
enough
you said i mean it's it it's almost like
you're always just trying to fit in but
actually once you own your narrative
once you're confident that
you are unique in whatever way it might
be
it might be a geeky kind of unique it
might be a cool kind of unique it might
be a quirky kind of unique
but that's if if you can own
your personality your narrative and
accept that you're halfway there
to this self-belief and this confidence
and and
that also means not trying to buy into
someone else's narrative you might think
you want to be the
if you're the geeky one you might think
you want to be the cool kid you might
think that you want to
be playing in the first football team
you might
think that you um want to be
sitting at that top table but that's not
necessarily where your personality um
uh wants you to be and i think
stop wanting and start being
very powerful i am it took me back to
something i read from this swedish
philosopher i can't remember his bloody
name but
he was talking about how when you try
and abandon your true
self you'll despair if you fail or
succeed
if you succeed in abandoning your true
self you'll despair because you've
abandoned yourself
if you fail you'll despair because you
you've attempted something and failed at
fitting in
so he took the conclusive point of this
flowchart he wrote 200 years ago was
that
the only way to fulfillment is to to to
be
um and i just i mean very very powerful
and your your story is um incredibly
inspiring for so many reasons but i
think mainly because of your
willingness to share it so honestly all
parts of your story and i know that will
help a ton of people because
the stories that you've told me about
yourself especially when you're younger
and the lack of confidence are
it's my dm's are full of young men young
you know women that are
desperately trying to uh um understand
why they
um they don't feel adequate and so i
want to thank you for coming here today
thank you yeah it's truly fascinating i
don't know what i was expecting us to
talk about but i'm glad we talked about
all the topics we did um and i just hope
that you know
we we could do a lot more people in the
world that are willing to be as
transparent and honest
um um warts and all so thank you so much
because this is exactly why i started
this podcast
and it's gonna be super valuable to all
the people that listen well listen thank
you so much
it's been a pleasure being here thank
[Music]
you
[Music]